This episode is supported by 23andMe (23 and I)
There are currently 7.5 billion people living on Earth
who 323 million live in the United States
As global power, many have views on American livelihoods.
But what do the statistics say,
and what would happen if we all lived as Americans?
First you would have done more sex.
Studies show that Americans have sex on average 138 times a year
which is the second highest in the world after France.
Porn would be more than 73% of porn in the world is produced in America.
Americans drive the 13th mile and four hundred and seventy-six miles (13,476) miles a year,
which is the largest in the world.
This explains why they have the world's highest car crash rates
and the number of meals eaten in the car
Seriously. Statistics show that 20% of American meals are consumed in a vehicle.
Americans eat on average 8 ounces of meat every day
which is almost twice the world's average.
This leads to the killing and eating of 10 billion animals annually by Americans,
which is 15% of the world's total consumption.
The average American also drinks 403 Coca Cola products every year
compared to the world average of 92.
All this leads to the US having the highest total calorie intake,
getting sugar, and getting the fat
compared to all the other 16 richest countries.
But consumption is similar in one category: fruit and vegetable consumption.
And all this eating leads to fertilizers,
Americans throw 1.6 billion pounds and 220 million car tires annually.
An American individual produces 729 kg of fertilizer each year
of which 544 kg are organic waste.
This means that the population of America
which is roughly 5% of the world,
draws 40% of the world's waste.
For most of the world, the lifestyle of Americans meant to live longer.
The US life expectancy is 82.1 for women, and 77.5 for men.
But it's still ranked 42th in the world after other industrialized nations like Australia and Canada.
This is possible because these countries have publicly funded health care better.
The average age in the United States is 37.9
which means if you would divide the entire population of America into two equal groups,
half of the people would be younger than 37.9,
and the other half would be older.
America is characterized as having an aging population
as the average age of the world is 30.1.
Nigeria has the lowest average age of 15.3,
compared to Japan, where aging can become a problem
as their average age is 46.9.
An American's lifestyle requires about 10 liters of oil each day.
But some other developed countries consume more on average, such as canadje,
who use 10.2 liters each day,
while some of the smallest consumers of oil are the citizens of Bangladesh
who use 0.1 liters every day.
A direct way to measure the impact of the world
changed to American livelihood is using global hectare.
This measurement looks at how much land, sea and other natural resources are needed to produce
what each person consumes each year.
For example: eating rice, buying furniture, or clothes they wear.
An average man in the world uses 2.7 acres worldwide every year.
The highest is the livelihood of citizens in Kuwait who use 8.9 hectares worldwide every year,
With the US a little behind using 6.8 acres worldwide every year.
With the amount of CO2 (carbon dioxide) freed from this,
studies indicate that we would need another half of Earth
to absorb it at a safe pace.
But some other studies suggest that these are underestimates.
So you can imagine whether we would all live like Americans,
it would be catastrophic.
In fact, we would need 4.1 Earth to keep everyone living as Americans.
We thank 23andMe for sponsoring this video.
If you wanted to understand your DNA,
and to see where your ancestors came from,
or as your DNA influences physical features and health
then check 23andMe / asap
We have tried it ourselves and discovered that Greg has a large share of DNA from the Netherlands,
while Mitch discovered why he liked pizza so much.
All that needs to be done is to blot in a tube,
and they will analyze 23 couples of chromosomes
from which the name has also come.
Again go to 23andMe / asap
to find out more about yourself.